Vanessa Bryant shared another tribute to
her late husband Kobe on Wednesday
alongside a smiling photo of the
basketball icon she wrote quote miss you
so much and miss you sang bonjourno
príncipe sir Raina
Vanessa posted another tribute shortly
after this one about Gigi she wrote I've
been so lucky to have woken up to see
her gorgeous face an amazing smile for
13 years wish it would have been until
my last breath a source told ET last
month that vanessa is quote completely
shocked and heartbroken but is trying to
stay as strong as she can in front of
her children ET recently caught up with
friends and admirers of the former Laker
who are still processing the Bryant's
family tragedy ask you you know it's
been a tough week for your family Laker
family just your thoughts on Kobe I know
your dad and your mom really posted some
very endearing very sweet things yeah we
only have the best memories about him
and he's always been a you know an
amazing man and you know his legacy will
live on and I really just think that you
know that's what we just need to focus
on and you know he'll never be forgotten
and all of the amazing things that he
did and honestly this legacy will
continue to do is you know what really
were what I'm focused on so I'm just
looking at the positive aspects with all
of it you have covered some of the
biggest news stories in the world when
this Kobe Bryant story broke what went
through your mind and how did you
process this I think like everybody else
you know you're not a journalist when
something devastating it happens you're
just a human being and it was crushing
well it's obviously a tragic loss that
everybody's feeling I Kobe his daughter
you know they're the other family
members his family members the other
people who were on the board of the
helicopter it's just tragic you know
it's just a reminder that you know and
we always know that life is so short
always all the people that you love call
them and remind them as often as
possible
and I cherish every moment
[Music]